[Música]
el Primer Ministro de Israel y Benjamín
netanyahu prometió una respuesta fuerte
y precisa tras los recientes hechos en
Jerusalén este la policía de Israel
detuvo a un adolescente palestino que
abrió fuego e hirió a dos personas la
autoridad nacional Palestina acusa a
Israel de la escalada de violencia
la presidencia de Perú lamentó que el
congreso rechazara adelantar las
elecciones generales a 2023 de momento
los comicios continúan previstos para
2026 pero El Ejecutivo Pide a los
legisladores pensar en el bien del país
y ceder a uno de los principales
reclamos de las protestas
los combates de la guerra en Ucrania se
intensifican en la línea de frente del
donbash este sábado
Moscú acusó a Ucrania de matar a 14
personas en un hospital de lugansk y que
señaló que un ataque con misiles rusos
causó la muerte de tres civiles en
Indonesia
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez +
deut y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición informativa en
Jerusalén porque según la policía de
Israel este sábado un adolescente
palestino hirió con arma de fuego a dos
hombres judíos Joe biden quien
reiteradamente recordemos ha defendido
la solución de los dos estados y llamó a
Benjamin nettanyahu para abordar el caso
la Unión Europea instó a Tel aviv a usar
la fuerza letal solo como último recurso
sin embargo el Primer Ministro israelí
prometió una respuesta contundente a los
hechos mientras Naciones Unidas pide el
fin de la Jordania ocupada Y es que el
incidente ocurre en medio de la
intensificación del conflicto derivada
de la ocupación israelí de los
territorios palestinos en la discordania
ocupada la espiral de violencia no Da
señales determinar fue aquí en Jerusalén
este la parte de la ciudad Santa ocupada
por Israel desde 1967 donde un
adolescente palestino disparó e hirió a
dos personas este sábado
por lo que entendemos se trata de una
emboscada de un terrorista de 13 años
esperó para emboscar a civiles que se
encontraban en la zona el ataque se
produjo contra cinco personas que hacían
sus oraciones tenemos dos civiles en
estado crítico un padre y un hijo el
agresor por su parte está bajo custodia
policial luego de que dos civiles
lograran herirlo tras el ataque
en estos momentos el terrorista se
encuentran en el hospital donde fue
enviado por las fuerzas y lo que sabemos
es que se trata de un aumento
significativo en el nivel del terror
se produce en el contexto de una
repentina escalada del conflicto
palestino israelí el viernes un
palestino de 21 años residente en
Jerusalén este disparó y mató a siete
fieles cerca de una sinagoga antes de
ser abatido por la policía ataques que
se cree son en represalia luego de que
el ejército israelí llevara a cabo su
incursión más Sangrienta en sus Jordania
en dos décadas asesinando el 26 de enero
a nueve palestinos en el campo de
refugiados de jenning estos dramáticos
acontecimientos obligaron a cambiar la
agenda de la visita oficial del
secretario de estado Anthony blinquen a
Israel y a los territorios palestinos se
espera que el jefe de la diplomacia
estadounidense dialogue a puertas
cerrada con el gobierno israelí de
extrema derecha cuyas políticas
preocupan a la Casa Blanca
vamos con noticias de América Latina la
presidencia de Perú lamentó que el
congreso haya rechazado la propuesta de
adelantar las elecciones generales a
octubre de 2023 un proyecto de ley que
presentó el gobierno de Dina boluarte y
que se hundió en el legislativo con 65
votos en contra este sábado la
presidencia publicó un mensaje de
Twitter en el que pide a los
congresistas que piensen en el interés
nacional dado que el adelanto electoral
así como la renuncia de boluarte son las
principales demandas de las protestas de
hecho la bancada oficialista solicitó
que el proyecto se vuelva a votar el
próximo lunes este fue el tuit
lamentamos que el congreso de la
República no haya logrado ponerse de
acuerdo para definir la fecha de las
elecciones generales donde las peruanas
y peruanos puedan elegir libre y
democráticamente a las nuevas
autoridades exhortamos a las bancadas a
deponer sus intereses partidarios y
grupales Y colocar por encima los
intereses del Perú nuestra ciudadanas y
ciudadanos esperan con prontitud una
respuesta clara que permita allanar una
salida a la crisis política y construir
la paz social
y previamente nuestro corresponsal en
Lima Francisco Zacarías nos explicaba
Cuáles son las alternativas del gobierno
de Dina boluarte si este lunes el
congreso de Perú vuelve a rechazar la
propuesta ejecutiva de adelantar las
elecciones generales
Fuentes consultadas para este reporte me
afirman que la presidenta Dina boluarte
estaría evaluando las estrategias a
seguir para que el congreso de Perú
defina El adelanto de las elecciones la
más importante de ellas sería enviar al
Primer Ministro Alberto tarola al
congreso para que haga cuestión de
confianza y pida al poder legislativo
que defina el adelanto electoral en el
caso extremo que el congreso de este
país niegue dos pedidos de confianza la
presidenta Dina boluarte queda
facultalmente capacitada para disolver
el congreso y ella misma convocar a un
adelanto de las elecciones para este
2023 algunos analistas coinciden en que
esta sería la única salida para que
Paulo arte saque adelante de la Reforma
que visto por todos el parlamento
peruano no tiene voluntad de atender
desoyendo el pedido de los peruanos en
especial los manifestantes que tienen en
jaque a este país con bloqueos y las
protestas que han ocasionado la muerte
de más de 50 personas y también han
producido más de mil quinientos heridos
vamos a Estados Unidos porque al menos
tres personas murieron y cuatro
resultaron heridas en un tiroteo durante
la madrugada de este sábado en Los
Ángeles de momento las autoridades no
han comunicado el móvil del agresor sin
embargo el incidente causó especial
conmoción al producirse pocos días
después de otros dos tiroteos masivos en
el estado de California en los que en
total murieron 18 personas
y cientos de personas se manifestaron
pacíficamente también en Estados Unidos
contra la violencia policial las
protestas responden a la conmoción
causada por la muerte de tariri Nichols
a manos de la policía de menfis ayer
viernes se filtró el vídeo en el que se
ve a varios agentes dar una paliza al
joven afroamericano que murió tras
sucumbir a sus heridas los agentes
involucrados y han sido imputados por
asesinato en segundo grado más de dos
años después del asesinato de George
Floyd en otro acto de violencia policial
Defensores de Derechos Humanos se
declaran frustrados líderes sociales del
estado de Tennessee piden que se
esclarezcan los hechos y aman a más
protestas pacíficas
pido que investiguen más a fondo esto
parece que puede haber algo más detrás
de Esto para mí es mi intuición no tengo
ningún hecho pero sacaron a un hombre de
un auto sin ninguna razón y comenzaron a
darle la paliza de su vida es como si
algo más pudiera estar al acecho
hay más en la historia y creo que los
ciudadanos de Memphis y el condado de
Shelby merecen saber toda la historia lo
antes posible
cambiamos de información porque tras 11
meses de Invasión rusa de Ucrania los
combates se intensifican en la zona del
Don vast este sábado el Ministerio de
defensa de Rusia acusó al ejército
ucraniano de atacar un hospital en la
zona prorrusa de lugansk como resultado
del ataque otras 24 personas habrían
resultado heridas según las autoridades
de Moscú
por otro lado kiev anunció este sábado
también la muerte de tres civiles
resultado de una nueva ofensiva rusa con
misiles en el este dedoniasc de hecho el
presidente Voló lensky calificó la
situación endonia es de extremadamente
grave más detalles en el siguiente
informe
devastación en las calles de consta la
ciudad del este de Ucrania fue alcanzada
por misiles rusos el sábado tres
personas perdieron la vida Mientras que
otras quedaron en medio de los escombros
incluido este hombre que sólo recuperó
la matrícula de su coche algunos
tuvieron suerte de estar fuera de sus
casas durante el ataque mientras que a
otros los tomó desprevenidos
[Música]
estaba sentada viendo la televisión la
televisión estaba allí
en un momento hay un fuerte ruido no
entendía nada cerré los ojos abrir los
ojos y todo había estallado
estaba cubierta de sangre
más al oeste Nicole en la frontera entre
los territorios controlados por Ucrania
y Rusia los constantes bombardeos de las
fuerzas rusas hacen la vida casi
imposible y hacen que algunos residentes
piensen en evacuar
no hay palabras para esto disparan todos
los días cada vez yo vivo aquí sus
disparos siempre pasan por encima de mi
casa siempre están volando
que disparan los cohetes no puedo dormir
cuando llegamos por la mañana solo
encontramos cenizas no tengo nada que
decirle a esa gente son inhumanos y no
hay nada que decirle a esta gente
inhumana los ataques rusos se han
intensificado en el este y el centro de
Ucrania en los últimos días mientras
Moscú despliega el arma más eficaz de su
Arsenal contra los residentes los
ataques de artillería han dejado un
rastro de ruinas en muchas ciudades
entre ellas aquí en bulevar cerca de
donietsk Ucrania Confía en que el
aumento de la ayuda militar de occidente
anunciado esta semana como los tanques
estadounidenses abrams y alemanes
leopardos cambie la marea de la guerra
pero por el momento no sirven de
Consuelo a la asediada población del
este de Ucrania
un antiguo jefe del ejército de
República Checa será el nuevo presidente
del país tras haber sido elegido con el
57% de los votos en la segunda vuelta
presidencial unos comicios con una
participación récord de casi el
70%. el presidente electo exmilitar de
la otan petre Pavel se enfrentaba al
multimillonario andrei babish quien fue
Primer Ministro del país entre 2017 y
2021 y quien ya reconoció su derrota
Pavel cuenta con el apoyo del gobierno
de Centro derecha en el poder y entre
otras cosas respalda a la Unión Europea
en su ayuda Ucrania
entiendo que haya algunos que estén
decepcionados porque no ganó su
candidato Favorito pero también veo que
en este país no tenemos votantes
ganadores o perdedores
veo que ganaron valores en esta elección
valores como la verdad la dignidad el
respeto y la humildad
me gustaría que él fuera el presidente
de todos los ciudadanos de República
Checa que viera sus problemas y luchara
por los intereses de la República Checa
me gustaría agradecer mucho a nuestros
votantes
este 28 de enero se celebra el Día
Mundial por la reducción de las
emisiones de CO2 una jornada destinada a
crear conciencia sobre la crisis
climática Y es que desde la era
preindustrial es decir antes de 1850 la
temperatura del planeta ha más de un
grado Celsius lo que complica el
cumplimiento del acuerdo de París de
limitar el calentamiento global a uno
punto cinco grados en este siglo
y decenas de personas de la comunidad
indígena ya no mami ubicada en la
amazonía de Brasil necesitan atención
médica por enfermedades que aseguran
están causadas por la minería ilegal Se
ha registrado por ejemplo un repunte de
malaria en los pozos de agua estancada
que deja la explotación minera una
situación que se agravó durante la
presidencia de Jair bolsonaro Ramiro cué
Barberena nos cuenta más
neumonía malaria diarrea infecciones de
piel y desnutrición infantil en
distintos grados la comunidad llanumami
de Brasil continúa sufriendo las
condiciones vulnerables de vida y la
ausencia de asistencia de salud
muchos están enfermos no hay comida
muchos de nuestros familiares han muerto
muchos ya no mamían muerto
se estima que 30.000 viven en el
territorio indígena más grande que tiene
Brasil equivalente al tamaño de Portugal
y donde 570 niños han muerto en los
últimos 3 años las enfermedades del
pueblo indígena desbordan la capacidad
del hospital de niños Santo Antonio el
único del estado de roraima al que
acuden en graves condiciones menores que
tienen entre 29 días y 12 años
las miradas apuntan a la aceleración de
la explotación minera que contaminó Ríos
mató animales arrebató fuentes de agua
potable generó charcos que originan
enfermedades y ocupó los pocos espacios
sanitarios
nos quedamos cuatro años sin asistencia
sanitaria en las comunidades 120
comunidades luchando por la vida más de
20.000 Mineros de oro en tierra indígena
llanomami con armas intimidando las
comunidades comunidades que viven con
miedo
el último 20 de enero el Gobierno
Federal declaró una emergencia de salud
pública y desde entonces se tendieron
hospitales de campaña para auxiliar a la
comunidad la situación de los yanumami
se agradó seriamente durante el gobierno
de Jair bolsonaro durante su mandato las
muertes dentro del grupo indígena de la
selva amazónica aumentaron un 28%
llegamos así al final de esta emisión
informativa a ustedes Muchísimas gracias
por su atención saben que pueden
continuar con más información en France
24 y France 24.com
[Música]